you're gonna see that's what's important
YouTube again I really wonder if face
coverings are gonna be like a permanent
part of our culture or do you guys think
it's just gonna be a contemporary people
campaign yeah yeah I think for Americans
I don't think it will be because we have
such a like our culture is such a [ __ ]
off my face so literally yes when I was
like oh I went to go work out at LA
Fitness in my city and you have to have
a face mask on and while I was working I
feel like I was suffocating it's on my
[ __ ] how do I keep this [ __ ] on and
everywhere I look everyone's already
slowly start to pull it off really so
everyone I think like with the American
culture because people are gonna like
follow directions here and eventually
it's just gonna be like [ __ ] this and I
know there's places in the OC which is
this the next county over and they're
already [ __ ] face masks you know what it
is we follow directions to a certain
point and then once we're like this is
stupid then but then it's stupid yeah
yeah no I was gonna say imma keep
wearing mine just cuz I think they're
cool yeah good looking wonder yeah I got
some cool ones and like and and good'd
put out some cool and some ha oh I see
make some money but he just bought a
large inventory of them so I think it's
pretty cool to wear my boyfriend's that
was telling me like Oh back then when
you used to wear when you wear a mask
like you would get beat up because you
know you're associated with like a bad
like you're a bad person or whatever and
I don't know Asia more than man Asia
right but I'm just saying like I don't
know I guess like when you're wearing
masks at the time like you're just
considered someone like as a part of the
gang so he was just saying that like oh
it's funny that back then and when you
wear a mask like you get beat up but
then if you don't wear a mask now you
get beautiful were they wearing a
medical mask that's like part of the
gangster culture was he just the
gangster he just got beat up all time
you could be and I wouldn't have no does
that mean he was a bad King sir if you
yeah it's not one of the good ones
or maybe he was just uh yeah maybe the
area he was in just didn't like nurses
maybe and it was like a whole beef no
nurses here doctors only doctors worry
man
oh [ __ ] okay never mind they have
different kind of mess all right well a
Swiss team has spent the past two years
so even before this coronavirus stuff
the past two years they have been
developing a transparent breathable
material in order to use them format
feed the purpose yeah if it's a Swiss
team there's holes on it you're gonna
like it
yeah Swiss cheese would be one-third
less than all other cheeses yeah I mean
price yeah for sure
mostly yeah you guys might be feeling
well it defeats the purpose what the
[ __ ] is the point of this that's stupid
well there's a good reason behind it the
reason why they wanted to develop this
is because they saw a need for pretty
much a need for empathy in the medical
career or medical field because a lot of
health care professionals have expressed
that when they are caring for sick
patients like particularly the elderly
or children that they're they're very
lonely in these like situations in these
rooms where they're all alone because
they're isolated for whatever illness
they have and then once a medical
professional comes in they're wearing a
mass oh they can't even see their face
they can't say that they're smiling they
can't like have any sort of empathy with
the patient which makes the patient feel
really alone I'll do it the ice so much
that you can show and there's a long way
I'm sorry you're going through this
you're not smiling because well as if I
saw their faces I'm like all like yeah
hey I can't wait to go this to go to
like see my friends next year and then
the doctors obviously be very mindful
what kind of expressions they are making
yeah that's like mainly the the reason
here as to why they wanted to create a
transparent is it protects though it
does it actually functions the same as
like the blue or the green or the white
mass
like Harold oh no they developed a very
special type of material where it does
have holes in it enough where like it
filters air coming in and allow air to
come out but so just like the same like
with those disposable mats that we
currently have but they were able to
develop a material that is like semi
transparent I guess that's better than
like them coming in a full hazmat suit
where they still have the screen yeah
and you could see their whole face yeah
but then I would be more afraid of they
came in with that then just like a small
piece of cloth I'm like oh [ __ ] I got
radiation or something yeah yeah for
real
I just want to show you my face they
were talking about how one of the people
on the team they had assisted with the
2015 Ebola outbreak in West Africa and
they saw the like the limitations at a
face mask pad to the point where a lot
of health care professionals they
actually were prints photos of
themselves smiling and then tape it to
their uniform we're then like the
patient's can see like this is what I
look like this is a smile you can get
because you're alone and like that
brings them happiness
yeah like cuz a lot like you know with
like emotions they they really play a
part in our health yeah yeah yeah so if
you're not feeling like any sort of
happy even it's just gonna make your
recovery but where do you like get more
doctors or comedians
yeah like hey I know you have a ball wa
can't be able to see it they said I just
have like clown noses on good you only
have a week there you go tell people
like you have three months left like how
do you know I think it's usually a
generalization of ia you're gonna start
declining pretty fast but like how do
they probably feel like a bunch of
people who have had it before dying
they're like oh this is the stage you're
in yeah yeah it's a guess that can be
wrong on that yeah and they're yeah
they're wrong all the time what sucks
for doctors is that they really have to
disconnect from that you know I'm saying
because they probably deal with so many
patients that died and shed so they
can't get too connected or else it's
like it's really hard on their mental
health and [ __ ] so I know a lot of them
they're like they kind of have to shut
that off
and because I know sometimes you know
when they got to deliver the news like
hey I'm sorry but you
your wife hasn't gotten a lot they can't
even they're not even allowed to be too
sympathetic you know we have like
grieving rooms where they tell them
something well their job is like
everyone's scariest day all right well
they actually have patient
representatives that are in the room
there with a doctor - like assist the
emotional part of that because it's
heavy for the doctor to also take that
home so it's such a tough job yeah I got
a home girl who's a nurse and um she
deals with like kids that are really
sick and then she's like she's like oh
she goes through it you know so the
homes like I need a break I can't I
can't deal with this
yeah same with like social workers and
stuff to deal with all that fun fact one
of the leading doctors in China that's
trying to find a cure for kovat is
actually my grandpa's a student Wow my
grandpa was his mentor my grandpa was
like a anesthesiologist Oh Shi yes dog
and I didn't know that until like one
night my mom she was like hey help me
take a picture of this picture and I was
like what do you mean and she's already
done see this guy and I know what does
random like guys I've never seen in my
life she and I was like gasps like he's
one of the leading doctors in China
right now and I was like why is like
that's your grandpa right there she's
like yeah he was your Grandpa's student
l like where do I come home yeah does
she get mad and like why you're not a
doctor
yeah no she doesn't which reminds me
what the [ __ ] Julia I know I do have a
doctor in the family we do have a doctor
in the family her brother yeah yeah yeah
yeah same are you from now we'll check
back in and see if he solved it or not
and then it'll be extra cool or extra
not that cool yeah that's him but he
like looks obviously older now but yeah
yeah I feel like it's easier to break
bad news if you're a doctor if there's
no loss I mean like if I was a doctor
I'd want to [ __ ] around all the time
sorry if it's like some of the motion
okay it's so fun like if someone had
like a call I would come in and talk to
someone who tricks his mom all the time
like I'm so sorry you're gonna die
tomorrow and I get to [ __ ] around and
you think just kidding and then you get
to have and then you
you're sb4 just playing around you're
right we shouldn't it's all about the
delivery delivery have you seen I don't
want to get sued I like [ __ ] around
by the money how would you deliver it
let's hear it depends on the person I
need to interact Julia - Julia what are
you coming in for first okay you make it
up yeah okay you came in here for a
happy foot okay sure Julia yeah I'm so
[ __ ] sorry but you have cancer off
the toe and it's spread it's very
malignant and we're gonna have to
amputate below the knee puzzle Annie why
not just like just my foot like just
kidding that's fine
I was wrong we all have fun that's fun I
love going through the motions I don't
like but now it's less I wouldn't have
to be from the knee down
why couldn't I think of Michael Scott
when he was pretending he's the holy or
have you seen that own Family Guy clip
where he goes doctor and the doctor
comes out he's like alright well there's
only two weeks left and then and then
and then uh Peters like what's and he's
like in my hell in my way let me wait ok
so he's like like there's only two weeks
left and then they're all alert and he's
like for my health club membership and
they're like oh and he's like well
anyways alright not gonna make it it's
like oh like to that appointment I have
for dinner because patient's are too
there's so many oh so funny I like a
receipt hi every scene of us a
development
yeah where they'll come in and if you
like Oh like your son is like don't
longer with us and then a one starts
crying he goes it was yeah we moved it
to the next room over because I was
later doing construction on this side
every single time is something about how
he like died or something Meredith when
she got it she he hit her at the car
yeah and then like it turns out that she
has rabies or whatever but then it was
like we lost Mary my childhood dentist
the one that used to live close to me I
would go there not to pull my tooth out
look at my tooth then you're like then
you take out like the biggest pliers
I've ever seen and I'm like not only
bees you just made it so fine like I
couldn't wait to go back there you got
in front so you keep like other things
like a big-ass syringe I don't need this
one either that's good
it just ends it'd be like a little like
q-tip that's like a little swab to a
slight nominee but then what does he do
any doesn't know dude I wish you could
[ __ ] the chainsaws things like I'm sorry
this is not a bit not this time buddy
this one's real Asians just no longer
trust them ever for anything yeah
[Music]
[Music]